welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host better call paul attorney at
ball in this video we're breaking down
episode one of she-hulk the new mcu
entry is filled with easter eggs cool
backs to the comics and a lot of things
you might have missed if you don't sit
around watching marvel movies all day
now as always we start off with the
marvel studios logo which features a
couple of new additions of the back of
the new movies we can catch doctor
strange featuring in the multiverse of
madness as well as jane foster from thor
love and thunder from here we go to
jennifer walters on a green background
which is of course a nice little visual
reference to the character she
transforms into here we see her
delivering a speech about power and
responsibility
what is the responsibility of those with
power now there's clear nods here to the
with great power comes great
responsibility speech by both uncle
bennet and may throughout the marvel
universe however this is also talking
about the power and responsibility that
she herself has throughout the episode
she says she doesn't want to be a hero
and instead she just wants to keep
practicing law eventually though she
steps up to the plate and in a courtroom
takes down titania played by jamila
jamil now we see that her law degree is
from the university of california and
there's also a ucla mug though most of
the episode is set in mexico we do know
that the majority of the series will
take place in la the show itself will be
heavily based on the dance slot run
which followed her being high to help
out superhumans the comic actually opens
with jen getting her law degree at
university but she's left alone and
doesn't really have any friends
throughout the comics she prefers to
stick to her she-hulk form because she
can't accept who she really is and she
lives a life of partying which this show
also seems to be doing on her book
cabinet we can catch a figurine or ruth
bader ginsburg one i believe is michelle
obama and to spell it out there's a book
that says badass women now she's going
through her closing arguments to her
paralegal colleague and friend nikki as
well as dennis who two features in the
comics he wants to deliver the argument
himself showing that men bloody men that
they're always trying to get in a
woman's way not me though i love him and
that's why everyone should hit the
thumbs up button and also subscribe
because i'm such a nice guy now dennis
also says that jen should listen to him
and not his paralegal friend and this is
very much reflected in bruce who two
thinks that jen should listen and do
exactly what he says once she brushes
them out her office she also breaks the
fourth wall for the very first time this
is something that the character is known
for in the comics and it constantly
allows her to explain what's going on
and also make offhand jokes this show is
very much about aiming stuff like ali
mcbeal which two used similar techniques
the procedural law drama will be
bringing across lots of big characters
and [ __ ] daredevil who we really want to
see is of course frogman now at this
point jennifer also says the following i
am a hulk uh and i'm guessing you're not
gonna be able to focus on this fun
lawyer show until you know all about
that so
let me get you up to speed cut back to
the road trip with jen and bruce and we
get this interesting line that's sort of
drowned out by the
narration it worked i mean my arm
started to heal and no one thought it
was yes that bruce now if you cast your
mind back to end game then you might
remember that carrying out the blade
caused him to severely damage his arm
however he showed up in the shanghai
post credits scene back in human form
with his arm still in the slaying that
he had at the end of endgame we get it
explained here and it turns out that the
device we saw in chongqi actually puts
him back in human form so that he can
save money on the cgi budget if they
need him to do it now he also points out
that jen eats cheetos with chopsticks so
she doesn't get cheeto fingers they end
up doing this later on in the episode
but the main mystery of the entire thing
revolves around if steve rogers is a
virgin or not something that definitely
matters and we all 100 want to know as
the guy didn't meet up with peggy until
after the events of endgame there are
further links to that movie with jen
talking about steve's ass in the
post-credits scene which of course calls
back to ant-man naming it america's ass
in the aforementioned film the credits
also have her with a bored and picture
of steve in his original uso uniform
there's an image of peggy carter along
with a chorus girl that appeared in the
show now we finally finally discover
that he lost his v card to a girl in
1943 as part of the uso show so yes
captain america [ __ ] this finally closes
off the biggest mystery since new
rockstars asked what he was cooking
[Music]
i tell you i'm i'm good friends with the
ceo of new rock stars phillip but if he
sees this video i'm [ __ ] dead now
this scene massively alters jennifer's
origins in the comics simplifying it by
quite a lot whilst also potentially
setting something up for hulk in the
future in this source material jen was
the daughter of an la county sheriff who
died in a car crash the day that bruce
showed up to tell her that he was the
hulk she was shot by a group of
gangsters and in the hospital bruce
ended up donating his blood to her since
there were no other donors available the
mobsters then arrived to finish the job
when she was laid up in bed and it was
during this that she transformed into
she-hulk it was also during her first
major arc in the comics that she fought
titania in the supreme court so they are
kind of playing fast and loose with
stuff especially the blood transfusion
now in the comics the transfusion is
what also allowed her to become she-hulk
whereas yet it's way more simple with
the blood just dripping into one of her
cuts however we do get hints towards
other comics if there's a car ship is
anything to go by though this looks
exactly like the grand master's vessel
we learn it's a courier from the planet
that's there to deliver a message
yeah it's the car in class a courier
craft they're probably trying to deliver
a message i gotta get to the bottom of
that now if the rumors about us getting
a world war hulk movie are true then
there are some things that this could be
in the comics bruce ended up living on
sakhara after the illuminati fired him
into space so that he would stop
destroying things on earth they believed
they'd send him to a peaceful planet but
when he arrived he was sold into slavery
and he ended up becoming a gladiator
zakar was overseen by an evil emperor
but throughout the run hulk created an
uprising and he overthrew him hulk
became the leader of the planet and he
ended up getting married whether the
ship he was sent in exploded killing her
and many securians and he returned to
earth in order to get revenge this led
into the events of world war hulk which
was a gigantic battle across america
involving lots of heroes hulk also
learned that he had a son on zakar and
it is possible that this ship came out
to inform him of something along these
lines hulk of course spent years on the
planet and who knows what he got up to
but i can imagine that hulk
now the ship forces them off the road
and we get somewhat of an homage to the
original 70s series the first
transformation in that involved bruce's
car breaking down and he ended up
changing into the hulk after getting
angry about not being able to move it
jen also has on similar clothes to how
brewster there with them having light
shirts on that ripper part however
whereas we got the hulk on full display
in the original yeah we see her changing
the reflection of the car which too has
a greenish hint to it hulk tells her to
get away reminding me a lot of when he
worn black widow in the original
avengers movie she runs through the
forest and in true hulk fashion wakes up
in the middle of nowhere this is
something that was too a staple of the
70s show and also the incredible hulk
movie due to him traveling to south
america it makes me wonder if the setup
he has near mexico was created because
of his closeness to the continent now we
don't know too much about the ins and
outs of what he did when he was down
there but he roughly spent about five
years before he settled in brazil now
blood also popped up in that movie and
it being leaked into a bot like the
factory he worked at gave us not only a
stanley cameo but it also led general
ross directly to him now jen enters a
bar at this point and we can see a qr
code on the wall which will give you a
free she-hulk comic if you go and scan
it in the bathroom she cleans herself up
and we also see ms marvel's symbol on a
chalkboard the avengers a also looks
like an anarchy sign and we can see a
spider there too outside the bar some
damn punks start harassing her and then
she transforms which is when hulk dives
in to stop it kicking off jen then
awakens in mexico at the hulk retreat
which is where she starts her training
and now it's time for jared's easter
eggs
[Music]
now this episode is filled with t-shirts
with band names on them jennifer is
rocking a led zeppelin shirt and then
hulk is later wearing a nirvana
nevermind t-shirt we find out that this
whole thing is set up by tony stark so
more than likely all of these t-shirts
actually belong to him because guess
what if you remember all the way back in
avengers he's wearing a black sabbath
t-shirt and then if we jump over to
ragnarok bruce banner is also wearing a
rio t-shirt from duran duran we also see
at one point what looks to be the helmet
of the iron legion this is all busted up
but does have a very similar design to
the very first form that ultron took i
like how
ultron just took one look at the
internet and decided us had to go i mean
two girls one cup
great decision my dude now this is
probably left behind as a reminder to
both bruce and tony because both of them
together created ultron in the mcu
[Music]
now bruce is back in the smart hulk form
as the inhibitor device is still bust up
we learn this is the gamma lab that he
brought up in end game and this 2 is
shown in more detail in a deleted scene
for the movie rip science bros and it's
clear tony's death still hangs over him
quite a lot they had a big friendship
that we weren't really privy to but
bruce of course popped up in iron man 3
with the movie being revealed to be a
therapy session for tony you learn that
the pair built the bar together but that
tony would just get drunk and moan about
steve bruce interestingly was used as a
mediator between the two and in infinity
war he was the one who of course reached
out to cap using tony's special cell
phone bruce also talks about some of the
times he's changed and he references
several of his films he brings up how he
fell out of a plane which is an odd to
either the incredible hulk or
potentially ragnarok when he changed on
asgard he also talks about how a robot
knocked him out i don't remember ultron
doing this so potentially this is a nod
to the hulkbuster fight might have been
knocked out by ultron but i can't
remember every single moment from all 34
of these mcu things cause look i need
some space in my brain for happy
memories i already can't remember my
wedding day because i replaced it with a
boss coming over for dinner at the end
of one division episode one please
please just let let me remember my kids
names please please
bruce clears up that it's only because
he and jen share similar genetic factors
that the pair can synthesize gamma as a
kid i used to think sticking my head in
the microwave with the door open would
give me superpowers but instead it just
turned me into a youtuber this is
something that has been explained in
more depth in the comics with only
really bruce and jen being able to
become the hulk if they're blasted with
gamma rays however other people can
synthesize this blood and use it on
themselves now we discovered that bruce
also completely healed his arm when he
was studying her you also get some
musical stings from endgame as he
destroys her blood in the incinerator
[Music]
it turns out bruce worries that there
could be other hulks created if her
blood gets out and we've seen this in
the comics there's a ton of hulk
offshoots such as a bomb red she hulk
the leader and so on and so on the
ladder was of course teased at all the
way back in the incredible hulk and it's
going to be interesting to see if he
pops up in the series a bruce really
worries she's not going to be able to
control her hulk side as he of course
had difficulty not turning into a
rage-filled monster he puts her through
her paces the first being trying to
trigger her transformation in a blinking
you'll miss a moment you might notice
that just before the blade starts
spinning that you can catch the stark
logo on them jen then busts out and
bruce worries she's gonna go wild but i
kind of feel the tension was robbed a
bit yeah cause we already know she's
gonna be in control thanks trailers
spoiler alert
now bruce tries to talk to her like
she's a stray horse mimicking the sun's
getting reload speech that was performed
by both black widow and thor in a
further call back to ragnarok bruce also
talks about there being another hand on
the wheel you really don't feel like
there's another hand on the wheel at all
no
this is a metaphor he also used when
describing what it's like to be bruce
and the hulk i mean in the past i always
felt like hulk and i each had a hand on
the wheel but this time it's like he had
the keys of the car and i was locked in
the trunk
he wants people to not see her as a
monster because that reputation never
goes away and the pair start to meditate
in a scene that feels very reminiscent
of the one from the incredible hulk in
which bruce tried to control his anger
it was also a deleted scene in that
movie in which bruce did it in order to
try and lower his temper with him taking
the position that he does here we know
this series is going to be acknowledging
that movie quite a lot with abomination
once more being played by tim roth
[Music]
now hulk sounds an air horn off in her
face known as the mighty honk this
causes her to crack the bed which is
something that also happened in the
dance slot run when she transformed
whilst she was in one jen wears a mexico
t-shirt and she later done the one with
isle of mexico on it this is similar to
the isle of la one that she had in the
source material hulk also gets her to
wear spandex so that they aren't
constantly tearing through their clothes
and don't wake up naked the pair then do
a training montage with jen also
punching the ground at one point this
also references the cover from the dance
slot series and we get a further nod to
it when they go to get drunk during the
comics after jen was kicked out of
avengers mansion and fired from her job
she went to a bar to get drunk they have
a section in which they explain how she
can't do this which is almost verbatim
to how it's said here now jim breezes
through the training with ease and she
also says that she can control her anger
because she's used to doing it as a
woman it's a bit kind of heavy-handed
isn't it and it feels like the sort of
thing they do in one of what's
commercials featuring brave mave now i'm
gonna out myself as a massive sexist
that will no doubt become the next henry
viii because there's no going back from
this i think my big i think yeah breaks
yourself my big issue with the first
episode is that there's no real room for
growth i think it's a basic part of
writing a main character that you start
off with them having flaws and
eventually they overcome these perfect
example of this is pray which features
naru slowly training learning from the
encounters she experiences and then when
she comes out on top at the end it feels
more triumphant now in the case of
she-hulk there's nothing in this episode
that actually holds her back and from
the off she's perfect at everything even
the titania fight at the end she just
changes sorts her out and that's it
there's no real struggle here which i
think is going to be difficult to
maintain over the next eight weeks
probably sounds like male fragility to
some people but to me yeah the most
interesting characters in the disney
plus shows have been wonder and lucky
because they're flawed now they might do
what they did in the comics where she
has to wrestle with accepting what side
of hers the real her but i kind of wish
they'd put some obstacles in place so
she wasn't immediately better at
everything than everyone else and she
seems to not really want to be she-hulk
so it'll probably end up being about her
accepting her role as a hero now because
of her getting through everything jen
just wants to go home and she goes to
take the jeep i love how she has to
adjust the seats as hulk was of course
riding it and it all ends up kicking off
cause jen knows best the pair ended up
fighting with hulk busting out his
signature thunderclap move that's been a
feature of the comics movies and games
jen quickly learns how to deal herself
and the fight leads to them breaking
bruce's ball the bear end up fixing it
up and then jen breaks the fourth wall
this is the first time it happens
chronologically and shout out to our
editor matt for saying that the first
time she did this was in the sensational
she-hulk she then carves the initials jw
into it to go with tony and bruce's go
to the present again and jen going
against who i believe is holding
holloway in the comics he ran the law
firm that dealt with superhuman affairs
and he ended up hiring jen after she was
fired from hers during the trial early
on she ended up being called out by the
avengers and this caused a recess the
next day when the jury ended up
deliberating they came back with a rapid
response which many believed was because
she was a superhero it was thought that
this could cause issues and possibly get
verdicts over turn due to mistrials
because of her influence so he let her
go and then holden stepped in and took
her under his wing jen has dealt with
lots of high-profile cases in the marvel
universe including the stamford bombing
that featured in civil war she
represented several of the heroes who
refused to join the superhuman
registration act and they might even
pull across parts of that storyline as
not everyone signed the sokovian accords
jen takes off his shoes and we watch as
she transforms with her hand changing
first this is a similar motion to what
bruce did in avengers during the always
angry scene we then get a fly a flying
drop kick
looks great that and jen beats titania
pretty easily no idea who she's there
for but the case in the comics was for
antarctic vibranium which had been
poisoning lots of people titania seems
to be there looking like the ultimate
warrior for another reason and the pair
had a major rivalry in the comics this
was also explored during the dance slot
run and after she goes out like a chump
i'm expecting to see her back now it's a
bit of a sloppy fight and i don't know
if it's intentionally meant to look
because it's imitating ally mcbeal or if
it's just genuinely sh
either way that wraps up the episode and
we see the credits play out this
contains court scenes with jen
practicing law in her she-hulk form we
see her with an avengers mug that's
likely a murder weapon lots of cheese
puffs a spandex sale and the captain
america virgin board looks like the kind
of thing your mates make about you as
well mate it all plays out to eaves
who's that girl and we also get a dating
profile shield file venice beach workout
scene and some people dressed as the
avengers outside laos chinese theater
these are all presented like a courtroom
sketch which we also see an artist doing
kind of tying this all together that
closes it out after the post credit
scene and i kind of went over my
thoughts a bit in this uh but just to
sum it up i thought it was an okay
episode hulk is actually my favorite
marvel character so i'm always happy to
see the guy i just felt like this was a
bit unbalanced pacing wise he spent a
lot of time doing experiments training
and all in all it didn't really amount
to much as there wasn't really anything
jennifer had to overcome so the time we
spent here i think could have been
better spent elsewhere and normally when
someone's an expert at everything they
use that time for character development
but yeah we didn't really progress all
that much i also feel like the
transformation massively toned down the
comics as that had quite a dangerous
origin story for her whereas yeah they
just got off the road and some blood
gets in her arm really robs the stakes
that created her in the comics and then
coming to grips with her powers is also
glossed over too should call it the
mid-credible hulk because as far as
origin stories go i think this is one of
the mcu's most forgettable probably in
the minority as my editor matt really
loved the show i just feel like i wish
we'd seen a bit more in terms of growth
and where she's gonna go i might end up
firing her next time like in the comics
and then she's gotta climb her way back
up but just taking this as all i've seen
so far
yeah i kind of feel that there could
have been a bit more growth obviously
we're really really early on and the
show can turn it around for me so i'm
not counting it out yet
just feel a bit meh on the on the first
episode now i don't know if you've been
following me for a while or whatever but
i normally don't write origin stories
that much because it's all sort of going
through the motions so maybe next time
i'll enjoy it a lot more hopefully you
join me and i'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comment section below
now we're running a competition right
now and giving away three copies of top
gun maverick on the 15th of september
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want emails to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
original plan for marvel which will be
linked on screen right now we go over
what kevin feige originally wanted to do
with the characters that he had and it's
definitely worth checking out if you
just want to know a bit of trivia if not
then thanks for sticking through the
video i've been paul i'll see you next
time take care peace